if I've called your question right semi
it's the there's a number of issues
you're raising I background to my
response would be this paradox of the
day ified defiled reality the young
yamanouchi as she is affectionately
addressed by participants in the
conference who are practicing
religionists to use that any the sense
that srivatsa goswami is the leader of
radha raman temple in Vrindavan and he
will say things like two points when his
grandmother died it is customary to
bathe the body in the waters of the
Yamuna River and he could not do that
and this is not something I'm not
talking millennia here at the beginning
of industrial people were swimming in
the Yamuna River in Vrindavan in the 70s
people were drinking the water it might
be problematic for some of us but the
water was still a potable in that sense
so we're not talking decades overly many
decades or certainly not centuries and
so the Srivatsa Goswami it was his first
encounter with the reality of this
situation he they have a well which
penetrates quite deep into the ground
and they're calling that yum in the
water and so that's what they're washing
the body so that deceased and also
rituals that require water from the
yamna so that the sense of this bhakti
relationship he feels he cannot publicly
speak frankly about his understanding of
the Yamuna River in its pollution
because it's too challenging to the
faith of the community that he serves
and too challenging to the thousands
tens of thousands of pilgrims who come
to Vrindavan on the other hand he also
feels this
is an opportunity for education from the
standpoint of the needs as you mention
it and from the standpoint of the faith
the devotion of the people who are
coming to begin to even visit such basic
exchanges as the prasad from the temple
that when the pilgrims come the exchange
with the temple of a gift-giving from
the temple to the pilgrims often in the
form of a particular suite or an
offering a food offering maybe even a
meal given back by the various temples
to the pilgrims who visit and some
thinking now about tree planting
literally placing in pilgrims hands and
guidance how to plant the trees and
where to plant them the sense of an
educational exchange about water
catchment water conservation along with
prasad or these kinds of issues that we
would respond not simply to a kanay
constructed environmental agenda but
would also try and meet need to educate
people to what their need is calling
forth from out of the environmental
realities along with their sense of
their love for the river and it is a
lovely river it's like so many
environmental realities the the
mountaintop removal also masked by its
it's being raised up in the trees and so
also the yamen at any given moment you
know you look at it that she looks
beautiful she looks lovely but when you
go down to get close to it the reality
is stunning